I've just done a film about a special
class of Turing machine called busy
beaver that enables you to play the busy
bee of the game so there's lots of
wonderful video 40g that you can see on
that however for those of you new to
this game who aren't familiar at all
with how Turing machines work what we've
now done is sectioned off a little piece
of footage that you could watch first of
all to get some idea of rod owes Tebow
Rado who invented the busy beaver game
how he designed his particular Turing
machine to enable this game to be played
first of all what does the cheering
machine actually look like what does it
do so here we are there this is a Turing
machine tape is divided up into lots and
lots of notional cells these are memory
locations into these memory locations
you can put patterns of bits that
represent your program patterns of bits
that represent the data you're working
on in the data part of memory and you
can have an infinite amount of it in
principle the only other thing you need
to give this universal computing model
is a read/write head it visits a
location on the tape and you can either
issue to it a read command or a write
command now suppose these cells have
been pre initialized with zeros if in
the current head position you say read
and tell me what it is it says it's a
zero
you can then if you want to say I'm
going to overwrite that with a one so in
every cell of this memory there is the
ability to be raised and optionally to
overwrite with something else now you
can if you're completely masochistic and
some chewing machine programs work out
like this you could always overwrite a
zero with a zero doesn't going to stop
you doing that so it can shift left or
right or not at all and this is a binary
Turing machine there are other
formulations which try to make life
simpler and keep the tape shorter by
saying oh I'll let you work in decimal
arithmetic what was discovered very
early on was it really didn't matter
how fancy your alphabet was for the tape
all cheering machines are the same they
all had the same computing power it's
just that sometimes you can keep the
tape length shorter okay so where does
the program come from that causes this
head to read and to write and to shift
in many Turing machine primers you say
let's park the program code as tons of
ones and zeroes at this end of the tape
and data in memory at the top end of the
tape and you'll read an instruction it
will tell you something to do with the
read/write head and you'll shift the
head up into the data section you'll do
it your oscillating back between reading
program writing data the simplification
I'm going to do which is what T Berardo
does on his busy beaver Turing machine
and it makes life so much simpler but
I'm going to take the program code off
from tape so I could O fashion computing
on two cards not punch cards of the sort
we've covered but a Tebow Rado card
here's a typical Tebow rado type Turing
machine card and the idea is that every
card represents an instruction in the
Turing machine so let us look at this
card in the context of this Turing
machine tape here
Tibor says for the sake of argument
let's assume that all these data memory
cells are initialized to zero since you
don't know whether the head is going to
shift to the right a lot or shift to the
left or look ahead of time let's put it
in the middle of this tape here zero
here means if you've got zero under the
head at the moment in other words you
read and you see a zero it then says
here the one is character to be written
so we have read a zero it now says write
a one second binary digit here says now
move the head and again what Rado did is
not absolutely essential in Turing
machine law she said if I make the
Turing machine world like this
it's a lot easier to show you what's
going on so please forgive me in the
Rado machine the head must always move
you can't say no I'm stopping still here
you either move left will you move right
zero equals left one equals right and
then finally what's this - we're that's
your next instruction - we run card one
your next instruction will be on another
card card - so you've got all of these
actions that must happen if you read a
zero in this current state of the
machine c1 is the start card c0 is the
halt card
okay so if something in one of these
instructions says your next card is zero
you know the zero card is the whole card
so that's the general layout of these
cards well now have you seen this
introduction I'd encourage you to go on
and watch the main busy beaver movie and
I think at the end of that you'll get
some real feeling for just what the word
undecidability actually means
if it doesn't hold we get a no answer
but then it holds so if it does hold
then it doesn't hold but if it doesn't
hold then it does hold either way we get
a contradiction it's a paradox